the federal debt limit and the
possibility of a government default will
be on the table again today when
President Biden meets with top
Congressional leaders it comes as the
treasury secretary issued a dire new
warning yesterday
Ouija Jang is at the White House Ouija
good morning
Nate good morning to you and good
morning to everybody a person familiar
with the discussions chelse CBS news
that we should not expect a breakthrough
at the end of this meeting but that in
recent days the two sides have made some
progress house Speaker Kevin McCarthy is
demanding that spending cuts be attached
to any deal to raise the debt ceiling
one area of potential compromise is
rescinding covid relief funds that have
been approved but not yet spent in a
letter to macarthy yesterday treasury
secretary Janet Yellen warned that if
Congress fails to raise the debt ceiling
it would cause severe hardship to
American families and harm our Global
Leadership position Yellen zutter comes
as the Office of Management and budget
or OMB released a memo this morning
saying proposed cuts by House
Republicans would cut at least 30
percent of all areas outside of Defense
the Veterans Affairs department and
Homeland Security with severe impacts on
programs including cancer research Meals
on Wheels for for seniors preschool and
child care and Veterans programs now it
is important to note that OMB is part of
the executive branch and the director is
appointed by the president secretary
Yellen warns that the U.S could run out
of money on June 1st or in the days
after that leaving little room little
time to reach a final deal President
Biden is set to leave tomorrow for the
G7 Summit in Japan Tony
all right Ouija thank you very much